AGAIN.
>> Brian: ALEC BURKS
THEY HAVE NUMBERS.
ISH SMITH.
OH MY GOGO ONE FOR SHAMET.
.
>> Jeff: GREAT ROTATION BY THE
LAKERS.
WHAT A LIKE THE FACT THAT HE'S
SENDING A MESSAGE TO HIM.
LOOK THIS, MAN.HE
OPEN LOOK.
GREAT PLAY BY THE SUNS.
PAUL CHASES
HANDS, DEFLECTION, OUT, A LITTL
MOMOSSELL WESTBROOK.
LIMPS OUT. FOLLOW
IT UP, AND THAT THE
RELATIONSH
PLUS THE FOUL.
AND NOW I'M PUT IT INTO THAT THE
THROW.
THAT IS OUR PLAY OF THE GAME
DAVIS AT THE BUZZER.
THE CAVALIERS BY 19.PELLS. OFFE.
I LOVE HIM FACILITATING THEED P
>> BACK DOOR CUT AND LOOK
WHAT T
THE ROOKIE
WHY ARE WEOING TO JUMP TOWE SAM
THREAT THE INTERIOR  JAREN.  LA.
BEHIND THE HEAD.
[ BU
THERE.THE
THERE IT I AND SCOOP UP
FOUR STEALS.
ISAAC OKORO GOOD!
AND.
AND A WIN FOR  GIVES THEM
GILGEOUS-ALEXANDER SENDS IT AND
GETS IT THE GAME  AWAY.
>> HE IS 65 FEETHE BOTTOM.